welcome to another morning show Marco
how you doing man good how are you tell
believe me a little bit about what you
do all right so my name is Marco Martino
and I'm the owner of the urban writers
it's a writing services company that I
built this year I decided to get into a
passive income last year I got it to
self-publishing and from there it kind
of just took off and it led me to
starting the company that I run today
the thing I have the hardest time with
is social media okay just cause I've
never first I've never been crazy about
it in general even prior to the business
thing like okay I like Facebook I just
joined strictly for business okay to
connect with other people I started IG
like a couple of months ago okay I'll be
not even that okay
so I've had this thing with social media
where I'm having a hard time with it
what's the block is putting myself out
there is one block another thing is like
what do I post okay
right now I have IG but I struggle to
post okay I don't want to just like snap
pictures of me all the time yeah yeah
right and just post so that's one thing
I'm struggling with I'm also like me and
my wife were both business partners and
we're start like we started to company
together and we're starting this power
couple channel where we want to teach
people about mindset a business and
relationship YouTube YouTube YouTube is
like where we're gonna okay you have all
of our content but yeah so that's what
you post that's what you post on your IG
mindset like whatever you feel people
can learn from don't start talking about
things that you don't know about right
like if you don't if you don't have a
private jet don't talk about how to buy
a private jet you know but but there's
things that you know that can help other
people right whether they're clients
that you've met whether there's people
at events that you've met whether it
becomes then your fans who start asking
you questions that you can then respond
to if you're posting content you're
either gonna be an entertainer or you're
gonna you're gonna teach me something
okay so I'm gonna have fun and sin
escape
for me right I'm gonna I hate my life
and I'm gonna watch your videos because
you make me laugh yeah or you're gonna
teach you something to help me build a
better life so the other becomes an
entertainment or kind of like an
educational yeah but it sounds like you
want to be on the educational side and
how people build something better right
yeah well that's okay I mean listen you
can always also mix him like if you
bring a little bit of humor to your
content that can help too so you want to
focus on on education awesome so then
you're a thought leader in what people
care about is what's in your mind right
so teach me to think like you think
that's what I want to do right so I want
to learn how you think so then you just
have to this probably a lot that you go
through that is just automatic for you
but it's different than what most people
see like walking into here yeah you see
thing you see this room differently than
most people would see the room right
from a different perspective different
the marketing of the mindset or
something how you deal with certain
situations will be different than how
most people deal with those situations
and it's so automatic for you or maybe
Natasha your wife same thing but but for
people outside who don't have the same
belief system or mindset as you okay
like that's weird that's why does he do
that and they need to explain it so you
want to teach me to think like you think
okay and then I use social media to kind
of do that right well do you recommend
like being on all platforms so YouTube
is still social media it's just
long-form right for the most part I
would say I like picking one but to be
honest to start I think Instagram is a
fastest way to build I think YouTube is
the best long-term way to build right
that's what I've been hearing
with YouTube if you have a video that's
three years old people are still
watching it if it's a good video yeah
and it's still it's evergreen like it
doesn't expire check my mindset it's
forever
right you're talking about trends for
2018 nobody there isn't happening one
yeah right but if you're talking about
educational stuff that you can use
forever then that video from three years
ago is still going to get views
you're in second video from three weeks
ago it's not gonna give you yeah right
like it's done it's insta it's it's fast
yeah so instagrams the fastest way to go
YouTube is the best for building
momentum long-term I wouldn't try to be
everywhere
I would I would get to my handle get
your name so that nobody else can take
it you got a you know Marco is such a
common name Marco I was trying to find
you an IgE so like so get so get the
name everywhere just so that you can own
it and I would almost mail in the
content just to just like whatever you
posted on IG you can post a Twitter you
post a LinkedIn mm-hmm and you listen so
you listen to you listen to feedback on
Twitter if somebody tags you on
something like well we just came back
from vid summit yeah some people tagged
me on Twitter so we come attacked me on
IG some people tagged me on link then I
listen everywhere so if you go if you're
going to an event somebody might tag you
on Twitter and say hey man I met this
guy Marco he's talking mind said it was
awesome yeah but you never see it
because you're not paying attention on
Twitter I see you sir right so at least
listen so that if somebody says Marco
was awesome to meet you can you can
message back and make a video back to
say hey man thank you so much it's great
meeting you and what you do is empower
them to continue sharing and like right
because yeah if you're the if you're the
only guy write back to them on Twitter
they'll want to spread your message more
and dive deeper into your world and
they'll kind of like appreciate ya and
they and they already have a little bit
of an audience and so you're tapping
into their audience and hopefully then
then use they dive deeper into your
world and spread more of your message
right where if you don't if you just
ignore them then they're likely not
gonna keep right posting right right so
yeah so step one is you get all the
handles just to own them step two you
listen you know if you're not posting
any content most people won't be
shutting you out but you're listening
just in case because when you go to an
event like that mm-hmm people will shout
you out and you want to be listening
and in threes you start posting content
but you pick one primary and then you
use out the others as your secondary so
so for me YouTube is my primary and now
Instagram is also becoming you spend a
lot of time but I have it like I got
twenty four people will help me build
stuff up since it's a lot harder to do
it so though yeah I think most people
try to be everywhere and they suck
everywhere and then they never take off
anywhere because you're spread too thin
okay but if you're posted on IG then you
just take that and post that same thing
to Twitter and post the same thing to
LinkedIn so you have some content but
don't expect like made your lift on
those platforms until you actually pay
attention of those platforms so like
focus pick one focus on that and maybe
have like two secondaries yes so like so
what's your primary you gonna be YouTube
YouTube is gonna be are yeah I'm
thinking like YouTube and IG for sure
okay yeah so if you're doing YouTube and
IG YouTube's your long-form content so
if you're doing a show you could be 8
minutes 10 minutes half an hour an hour
whatever whatever feels right I use I
would use IG as one practice I think you
can get way more practice on IG okay
like stories yeah three stories a day on
IG to practice the practice the practice
being a thought leader to practice being
in front of the camera the practice like
what is my message today yeah because
you might run out of things to say so
like right okay the practice of comforts
cuz that's building the skill set so
that when you go to youtube you've been
in front of the camera and you're
comfortable right and you're not just
being a part of the camera but also like
figuring out what your thoughts are and
sharing them getting used to sharing
them so three times a day on on IG
stories is it's 15 seconds max 45
seconds out the day yeah you know it's
like yeah now there'll be some thinking
time a little bit around it but anytime
you're feeling or heightened emotion
okay film it just pop okay
whether you're you're pumped about
something like I just landed a new
client and or my client just got a book
deal because of me or whatever yeah or
or you're pissed like
discovered me off and pissed off or your
grateful or your like anything anything
heightened emotions get used to filming
it because what you want is when you get
to your YouTube channel you want to you
want to be able to tell stories that
mean something to you but it's it's
often hard to access those emotions
later so if you're gonna tell the story
of how with DM the grant cardone
yeah maybe that was a moment but it can
be hard to access it that now like three
weeks later or whatever right supposed
to the moment itself so if you record
yourself like you've right after that
like holy cow it just damn grant this is
crazy you know like guys just take a
shot you know whatever you whatever the
message is with it then two things one
you can always look back at that like if
you save it as a highlight you can go
back and look at it and say oh that's
what it that's what I felt like being
there so you can recall it faster but
also - you're used to articulating it
because when you when you experience
something you just you feel it but
you're not used to saying it so now
you've said it when you felt the moment
okay so you can more easily say it again
three weeks later three times a day IG
stories okay and especially when you're
feeling in heightened emotion it's like
after this go make an edgy story just
got done without it was like it was a
great thing of all time or that man Evan
sucks I hate that guy either way like
something hopefully you feel something
out of this right grateful happy sad
terrified angry or something and then
like and then spit that you know okay
like just the thought of me like right
after this going to do that yeah I'm
like nervous about it great yeah but so
you have to do it I think you could do
it right now
I don't know if I could yeah yeah you
can do that take off your mic then go
get your phone and do something right
now oh there it is perfect yeah Marco
loggers didn't do something right now
okay hey guys I'm here live with Evan
having an amazing time yes
[Applause]
okay I just posted okay great
no but that's it like your first thing
will always suck when you don't know
what you're doing it's gonna suck and
it's just taking like the good news is
everything you do after this won't suck
as hard as that one just in it right so
so then how you fix it is you gotta
gotta you gotta teach me to think like
you think so I'm having amazing time
with Evan awesome like why are we here
why don't you come here will you scared
are you nervous you want to tell people
like go do the thing you're afraid of
I'm I was terrified to me this is my
first post I'm terrified of this I'm
doing this live on it yeah anything but
but what you know when you get
challenged you be the guy who stands up
instead of who shrinks from a challenge
right right anything like so learning
the process what your head is going
through and then teach me to think like
you think as opposed to just showing cuz
somebody looking at that won't know what
it means
yeah all right so you have to go a level
deeper that's when people better than
connect with you as you kind of because
they'll understand cuz that's they'll
probably feel the same thing if they
were in that situation is that kind of
the connection yeah okay most of the
people who are following you won't be
challenged by me live on IG to go do
something right but they'll be they'll
be challenged in their life right by
different people for different things
right they'll go to an event and grant
challenges and are Gary challenges like
man what do you do when you get
challenged yeah you step up or do you
shrink right you got us yeah step up
that is something that they can relate
to so your your unique experience then
become something that everybody can
connect with right so like the people
watching here can connect with it cuz
they know a little bit more the context
and the sites they know I'm so nervous
even if I do they make me nervous great
let's do it now oh my god right now
I have my phone right so maybe that
inspires them to go ask that girl out or
ask for a raise or start their business
or just like just do it I thought is
just take the action that's it right so
so then teach me how to do that okay
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new to 54 confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days for free
I will send you a 30 second a five
minute video in the morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to learn the fastest way to
grow your channel check out the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there what do you think is the
fastest way to grow it has been growing
every day I am gaining subscribers but
it's not as quick as I thought it would
be